nuovo asti 27 kg 25 fatto una piccola
pausa cibo abbiamo fatto una piccola
pausa cibo già uil
praticamente un giorno è brutto mio
amico a trovarmi ho portato dei
superalcolici da bere abbiamo beviamo
che siamo attorno a casa mia morosa e ci
becca tutti il 2 con i pantaloni
abbassati a fare l'elicottero su e giù
per il caos saluto avete capito non lo
vogliono col dito con pose dirlo con
cosa certo contento è un brevetto di
pilota
la cosa più imbarazzante che ho fatto
quando ha bevuto stato nel tanto del
paese che armata da 4 mila abitanti 15
come un fabbro impresa dire sul pacco ne
toglie il mese ci siano e stare
l'elicottero con le tette carter di noi
che li cotto o è fattibile professione
di lunghezza prono questione del proprio
di aerodinamismo usi dice euro dinamica
aerodinamica aerodinamica una volta
quello di cercare di capire da lui
arrivare al terrore all'elicottero con
le zinne come fai a farlo se hai delle
un seno comunque prorompente puoi fare
questa cosa quasi vorremmo vedere una
foto del seno di questa persona
tagliamo le abbiamo nel pub di questa
adesso dei ragazzi voi non potete
vederlo quando si è andato a vedere il
profilo e vede che è una questione
scientifica ovviamente empirica beh beh
peccato non essere finito in quel pub
quella sera perché è stata perché non ha
nessuno di 4.000 peccato di non essere
simpatico
c'è un aspetto va indietro il gol
proprio brava complimenti complimenti
a presto che schifo una volta lo sai che
cosa ho fatto un peso un giorno siccome
non volevo lasciare il mio posto è
presente quanto è difficile trovare una
sede in un locale dove sedersi ma provo
una sedia chelsea ma sai che in mezzo
alla piazza dove io avessi per ciò che
avevo questa birra
la finisco miss k bb e se mi alzo è
finita mi rubano gioco della scorsa sono
riempito di nuovo la birra bicchiere di
birra ma viso o tavolo e così avevo il
mio il mio posto è nessuno si è reso
conto di niente
e poi chi lo aiuta ma qualcuno l'ha
toccata ha capito che era caldo io ho
riso e beli hanno capito che era colpa
mia anche perché non riuscivo a essere
serio che schifo andiamo avanti per
favore sordo sai che le tristi bevuta si
l'avrebbero per gioco e curiosità ciao
punta oltre a qualcosa che è stata fatta
da circa un anno fa
riecco con degli amici in un posto per
mangiare qualcosa poi noto una bella
ragazza con l'apparecchio è convinto che
fosse a debita distanza da me la povera
fanciulla cominciò a elencare una marea
di uscita del tipo che l'ebraismo e cose
così
ma niente che lo talmente ubriaco da non
rendere conto questa ragazza in realtà
fosse tipo mezzo metro quadro è bella a
quella ragazza non credo ilsinho questo
commento
sì con una farfallina posso dire ma tipo
farfalla farfalla e anche più corto e
farfalla farfalla farfalla farfalla così
puoi usare quello che puoi sulla parola
farfalla
[Risate]
[Musica]
basta sushi mamma mia
[Risate]
volevo raccontarti di quella volta in
cui un mio amico ha sostenuto un
monologo davanti a numerosi spettatori
in cui diceva che i ragazzi palermo c'è
migliore sostenendo vai e ti ho portato
è rimasto circa due ore fuori da casa
dopo di che è andato a letto ma
purtroppo non siamo solo io e guglielmo
qui a fare questo video e abbiamo un
disturbatore e quando ride poi farete di
tutto a posto godermi invece la senti
così
[Musica]
[Risate]
diceva già ma cosa che fa ridere
divertente 0 niente basta basta e che
stava la malattia buddha di naturale una
penna davanti con lui che cosa fanno
fatto da piccoli è quello il problema è
tutto lì
[Risate]
12 mentecatti riassorbendo siamo umani
niente ma poi cosa stai scrivendo che vi
stanno finendo
ciao volevo nemmeno cosa senza senso ti
sto mandando la registrazione mentre
stop
allora siete voi allora colpa vostra
allora sono la generosa lui ci è stato
più ricardi qualcosa faticavo racconti
con la volta che la ragazza del mio
amico si è aggiunto che ha fatto è che i
ragazzi io ho dovuto gli occhiali non ce
l'avevo quindi in questo video
parrocchia ragazzi ti prego dammi una
mano a chiuderla foto molto felice di
essere qui ma se poi così insieme
ragazzi giovani e bravi alla toga o di
presto video grazie mille per i commenti
che accetta e claudio capirai disturbate
utile utile indispensabile perché dire
come ogni volta vi chiedo di farmi
sapere questa parte quali sono state le
vostre esperienze con delle ubriacature
particolarmente divertenti ma farmi
sapere quali sono secondo voi di
suggerimento dei temi che vorreste
vedere il prossimo giovedì mettete dei
like mi piace
i tradimenti già nei fatti si ne
vendette già la fase le obbligato
reggere fatte non l'ho chiesto consiglio
dove andare sotto quando tempo fa basso
finire col tra dove sarà l'ultima volta
mi è sempre capitato possono diventare
succederà a quelli che vi caccioni prima
da farmi capire un pochino quindi scava
la cosa più grande uno si fa un'idea
capita poi li vedi un po tutti però
certo che ora non so più chiuderli linio
allora e ci sono molto stanco perché
veramente ridere così ce lo fa mai così
bene libere poi la conclusione che
comunque di base quando ci si ubriaca si
produce un sacco di kakà è un sacco di
pisa makeba schedina ok ciao
no cioè bella mora del discorso come
morale ma credo che ci sia proprio una
morale di un sacco di kakà